[Musique]
salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette nouvelle vidéo
alors aujourd'hui nouveau format qui va
tester sur la chaîne youtube de chess
comme france avec des vidéos plus
courtes entre 10 et 12 minutes où je
vais revenir sur des parties d'actu
alors la copie de 19 pays jugent pas
vraiment de partie en tournois réels
donc on va revenir sur des parties sympa
qui se sont joués sur check point com
est donc là pour la première on va
regarder la partie du ce battle qui
opposait les deux bras à l'équipe de
bitstream premiers échiquiers firoud
déjà pour les bras et maxime vachier
lagrave laâyoune beast pour
bitstream et donc on va tout de suite se
lancer des quatre pour fuir ou de
jacques cavallier f6 c4 g6 qui a réalisé
trois des cinq maxime qui dégaine son
répertoire habituel la grünfeld s'éprend
des cinq cavaliers prend des 5e quatre
cavaliers français trois pions france et
3 donc toujours cette même idée un
d'agrumes fun on laisse le centre au
blanc et on va vouloir le contre
attaquer avec les pions notamment ses
cinq pour s'en prendre à cette chaîne de
concert avec le fou donc maxime qui je
vous fous g7 justement fouet 3 et c5
donc met la pression sur le pion des 4
et donc sur la structure avec ces trois
noms pour le comprendre le pion n'est
pas possible de ski à ces trois prises
ali reza qui enlève la tour de la
diagonale et maxime qui joue petit rock
est une nouvelle fois si on prend le
pion c5 il va y avoir un drame à 5 et
les pions c3 et c5 sont très faibles on
va récupérer l'un ou l'autre est le 2ème
restera en plus faibles donc rock les
blanc gardent leur centre bien compact
dam des deux cavaliers 17 ans ici d'un
mât 5 plus jouer mes cavaliers 17
pourquoi pas cavalier f3 pour ali reza
et b6 donc le double fiant kétou côté 1
maxime vachier lagrave donc si les
blancs jouent eux cinq pour fermer le
fou deux cases noires après fou bessette
c'est le fou deux cases blanches qui se
met à jouer sur la grande diagonale donc
c'est un peu l'avantagent du double flux
enquête autant ferment touvre l'autre on
se tait quand même jouable un fou et de
six
mais voilà c'est l'idée de maxime aussi
avec ce double fiant kétou donc ali riza
qui joue fou détroit est ici maxime va
jouer un coup très thématique est
intéressant il va envoyer eux 5 à noter
que maxime jouer vraiment très vite un
scénic 3 + 0 et il a très vite pris
l'avantagé l'ascendant à la pendule donc
cinq coups responsable parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de prise possible et de coups
possibles pour les blancs avec des cinq
puis on prend 1,5 et puis on prend ces
cinq mais aussi ne rien faire donc et
blanc tu as un grand éventail de
possibilités mais maxime qui a réponse à
tout dans la partie la jouer des 5 juste
à noter que sur comprend 1,5 il veut
jouer tranquillement fou bessette rock
et reprendre en cinq avec les deux fous
qui sont grands ouverts - le blanc
pourrait compris n'est pas reprise prise
f4 ou g7 et à j'ai envie de dire sajoo 1
ces dépositions les blancs
toujours le centre mais les noirs ont
les deux fous braquer dessus donc y en a
un qui s'installe au centre l'autre qui
l'attaquent
pourquoi pas sur qui on prend ces cinq
dont collection prend 1,5
j'imagine juste un petit cahier français
5 et finalement balle et noir sont en
train de se développer sont plutôt
contents un cavalier bien placé a
préféré régler le problème plus tard du
fou mais pourra revivre éventuellement
par f8 c5
mais surtout on puisse 6 échange on
pourra reprendre de baies et on verra ce
qu'on en fait on aura gagné la paire de
fou donc pas un souci et sur roy qu'on
pourra éventuellement tout échanger sur
des 4 ou garder le statu quo à voir en
tout cas dans la partie la jouer des 5
assez logique donc il se crée un pion
pas ses protégés et ici si vous
souhaitez vous pouvez mettre sur pause
pour trouver le coup stratégique joué
par mvl et il a joué cavalier f6
excellent coup stratégique puisqu'il
veut faire qu'avec un huit cavaliers des
six maîtres lecavalier bloqueurs qui
sera tentaculaire et qui contrôlera
énormément de 4 à noter que sur quatre
ou cinq on peut jouer cavalier prend 2,4
et récupérer le pion grâce à la
découverte donc dans la partie
on va y revenir sur cavaliers affichent
6 il a joué dame c2 et là on va voir le
plan de maxime déroulé il va être
vraiment très instructif il fait
cavalier 8 donc vous voyez replace le
cavalier en bloqueurs cavaliers d2f 5
on en voit un peu à l'est le roy on va
avoir sa f3 cavaliers des six rock fait
recaler 6f 5000 cette horde de coût peut
être plus précis et maintenant il va pas
maintenir l'attention au centre ce qui
peut être une idée mais il va jouer avec
4 et ça ressemble à des zestes indienne
fief de gilles simon qui fait la
fermeture du centre
et maintenant h5 g4 on en voit sur le
roi donc vers placement du cahier en d6
et bim structure de type est indienne
donc changement de structure changement
de type de jeu carré lisse et 4g 4
maintenant le centre est complètement
fermée à on le on n'attaque plus qu'elle
prend des six dames prend décide donc
bien joué la part de fuir ou jack
élimine ce cavalier bloqué avancé que le
cavalier le meilleur bloqueur à la dame
voyelles elle bloque le pion mais elle
fait pas grand chose alors que le
cavalier lui l'a taclé pions devant là
du coup bien joué de la part de shiro
déjà eu 2 h simple on envoie est ici
firoud déjà qu'ils jouent faux h4 et je
trouve que c'est assez bien joué le truc
c'est que il veut bloquer le pion h
et quelque part provoqué fouet si ça
vous allez dire oui mais le fouet ou g7
et le mauvais fouet le fou f2 le bon fou
alors déjà bons fous mais il est bien
emmuré dans les pieds adverses ce qui
arrive parfois d'avoir le bon bout mais
ont muré dans les pieds adverses
donc qui est un peu moins actif que qui
ne pourrait l'être parce qu'il appelait
les pions fleurs forme des murs en face
et si on joue alors un coup comme damas
quatre l'idée de maxime chaya de faire
flouer f6 et quand on va faire alors je
vais mettre des coups n'importe quoi
c'est juste pour montrer quand on va
faire g3 du coup on va arriver face à un
conflit on attaquera le fou et on
forcera quelque part un échange et on
réussira à ouvrir la position alors ton
commençant parfois h4 qu'en supprimant
ce full web 2 com il va le faire dans la
partie
la différence c'est que au moment où on
jouera g3 genre on va on peut avancer
dans la partie ça c'est la partie faux
f6 donc les a eus fouache quatre fois f6
fou prend m6 tf6 à 4 donc voit un petit
peu avant c'est fou 17 tours ben et ça
me permettre d'illustrer 3f cette non la
parole en faut peu registre est un peu
plus loin bref cette a5
j'avance les coûts rapidement quand j'ai
eu 8 à bab tour à un tour mg6 donc les
noirs voiliers qui se place pour
attaquer le roi et le truc c'est que si
à la place de torres justice ont joué
j'ai 3 c'est à ce moment là que je
souhaitais le montrer mais les blancs
ils auront toujours éventuellement le
coup h3 pour pour faire une fermeture
qui sera possible après il faudra
réussir à sacrifier avec des fous prend
h3 mais là sur fou prend comprend et il
nous manque un tempo faudrait qu'on
puisse faire dame 3,3 pour
éventuellement mater et le temps de
faire dame des sept îles font rage et 2
et les blancs le temps de fermer le jeu
donc vous voyez le truc d'avoir supprimé
ce fou de cases noires ça permet sur g3
ne pas être obligé d'ouvrir la position
mais de pouvoir éventuellement jouer
aussi la fermeture
donc après tour à un maxime a joué tour
mg6 donc il commence à préparer des
pions prend et fourrages 3 et alireza
qui va très bien défendre parce qu'il va
faire tout race est maintenant et cette
tour en a 7 vallées le clou le fou 17 et
donc elles empêchent les velléités
offensives du fou dont on a besoin
d'inscription prend feu prend le fou
d'échangés de et on aurait besoin de
fois je crois mais on l'a pas donc
maxime après tour à 7 qui se dé cloud en
montant le roi alors le truc c'est que
si tu t'en es fuite il peut y avoir
quand le tour arrivant à des histoires
de tourbe et sept tours à huit avec le
roi qui peut se retrouver un petit peu à
l'étroit donc surtout racette qui joue
le clouage il a joué 3 et 6 donc il veut
monter éventuellement et repartir se
cacher en h6 où il sera plus en sécurité
du coup les blancs qui joueront à achat
maxime qui fait tourner g7 donc il
protège son fouillis libersa dam tour b
1 commence à s'en prendre aux pions
b 6 on va un petit peu avancé roigé cinq
tours à 600 prend aux pions g pour un f3
fut bref trois fous g4 donc maxime qui
veut supprimer les fous évidemment
surtout reprend dame prend tout reprend
pour prend on a pris deux tours pour la
dame donc ça va pour les noirs même si
les noirs sont peut-être pas gagnant
mais c'est un échange qui est même
plutôt à la faveur des noirs donc ali
reza qui va pas prendre en b6 il va
faire dame b2 il augmente la pression
mais maintenant tour bessette défend
dame b saint cloud et cette dame deux
fous g4 à maxime et bas vraiment joué
très vite en plus de cas l'iresa dont
qui met la pression
autant sur ali reza qui se balade avec
dame 8 pour essayer de passer par
derrière à noter peut-être que tours à
huit étaient plus forts mais ma foi ça
me n'est pas à la victoire n'ont plus
d'un qui fait damer 8 pour essayer de
mettre d échec par-derrière mesdames f6
vous voyez les noirs maxime qui couvre
complètement son roi tours à huit tours
h cette maxime tu vraiment bien se
défendre et qui défend aussi b6 qui
prépare peut-être h4h trois dames f8
échec g prend en fuite tourcoing f8 tour
à sept et tours b 8 donc s'en prend aux
pions b6 mais qui n'est pas vraiment
attaquer puisqu'ils auraient tour à un
matt maxime qui joue au roi g5
maintenant voyez les deux hommes qui
sont bien défendus et
donc maxime qui a bien défendu son pion
b mais ali reza qui a aussi bien défendu
son roi et maintenant ça va se jouer
j'ai envie de dire davantage de temps de
maxime ali reza qui aurait pu tenter
tour 8% prendre option eu 5 on peut pas
défendre paroisse et fils à cause de
tout en baies six échecs mais ç'a
fonctionné a pas vraiment parce qu'on
aurait pu faire quand même roy et six
femmes pourraient plus de défendre de
manière acrobatique parce qu'après tout
reprend b6 thiaroye f7 on aurait
l'impression qu'on le perd sur échec
mais le truc c'est qu'on attaque la tour
e 8 et on menace tour à un matt et les
noirs ont pas le temps et tout reprend
b6 aussi et les noirs ont pas le temps
de tout défendre bhatia trois menaces et
du coup si tu bouges le pion quoi en
fait on peut on vas pouvoir te prendre
là la tour en b6 en premier si tu prends
g6 ya m'attends à un tu peut pas s'en
sortir avec avec les blancs devra
prévoir et fils on aurait pu jouer h3 du
coup pour gagner en tempo sur le fou et
se libérer le roi fou prend f3 tour
prend des six échecs maintenant roi et
recettes pour pranger 6 mais ça aurait
pas suffi des noirs auraient réussi à
s'en sortir je passe la ligne rapidement
mais en gros ça aurait pu mener à une
nulle
une variante lambda mais un petit peu de
cette manière là où tout se seraient
échangé le pion blanc restent en a3 mais
ça marche pas pendant la partie
il aa donc attendez on va revenir où on
en était donc il n'a pas fait tourner 8
il a fait tourner un tour des six du
coup pour bloquer le pion tour j'ai huit
tours jécistes en g63 projet six tours
b1 à b5 et là maintenant
maxime est mieux puisque si on prend en
bessin qu il ya toujours un math et les
noirs vont pouvoir faire un super plan
ici après h3 il conserve le fou sur
l'échiquier et il va faire froid et six
recettes trois des six et vous allez
voir
donc les blancs vont jouer fouet 200
pompiers ont ils fait ces quatre ils se
fixent les pions maxime sur sa propre
couleur il va vouloir faire web six
recettes 3d 6-3 ses cinq tours à a3 et
envoyée il va réussir à faire ce plan
roigé 1 h 4 wild 2 3 et 6 3 au 3e set
food et 1/3 des six voiliers montres
leroy roi des deux
tours à deux échecs fou c'est deux fois
huit donc il se replace pour avoir des
fourrages 5 éventuellement roi c'est un
roi c5 et maintenant le roi est super
bien placé et on va pouvoir jouer et le
pion ces attaques et éventuellement les
b 4 pour entrer et aussi le plan tour à
sept tours g7 pour s'en prendre aux
pions g2 voire même mètres la tour en g3
pour s'en prendre à ces trois jets
d'oeufs et venir peut-être même avec
tours 3 s'en prendre à eux quatre fous
g6 fou prend 1,4 on va pouvoir faire le
tour avec la tour et remporter la partie
nous qui va mettre la tourangelle six
tours 1 et maintenant tout reprend g2
alors à noter que sur ton g6 tour g1
pour défendre le pion fonctionnait pas
du tout à cause de f3 donc qui jouer sur
le clouage mais comme je vous montrais
un même un plan à la tour j'ai trois
tours trois fous g6 vous prend 1,4 était
parfait donc surtout rejet 6 il a joué
tour à tour en g2 et maintenant la
partie est complètement gagnante pour
maxime
mais voilà les a abandonnés ici avec une
pièce de moi mais j'ai bien aimé la
partie et que pas mal de transition le
petit truc de structures des pions pour
jouer structure de pions pour jouer la
tactique est indienne avec le e5 un
lecavalier qui revenant des six ans
bloqueurs d'encaisser ces petits thèmes
stratégiques et puis la finale assez
sympa avec le roi qui est venu le pion
en c4 pour faire le petit mur le roi qui
est venu accompagner et après jouer la
faiblesse g2 donc une partie qui m'a plu
et j'espère qu'elle vous a plu aussi on
se retrouve très bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]